Okay, so about a week ago, I was on a little live stream and
I was with my husband and we're doing a scavenger hunt in Austin,
Texas. During the scavenger hunt, I thought that it was really
poorly planned out. The clues were stupid and I thought that
I gave some pretty salient advice and I felt that me and Ice
were equals.
It doesn't matter that you're putting on something. I'm not going
to act beneath you because you're someone putting on a content
that we get to participate in because it's a symbiotic relationship
where your content is because we're here and you're using your
platform to give us the space, right? So, nobody's above anyone.
You might make the most money on it, but what does that mean
really? Right? So, I said, "Hey, I think you maybe thought in
theory some of these clues were a good idea, but we don't. We're
going to need some hints because they're pretty convoluted and
I think that you talk a lot about how smart you are, but you
obviously weren't smart enough to make them workable for us.
Every single thing I said ended up being correct. Every
bit of critique I had ended up being completely correct. And
yet he kept saying that I was an idiot and he especially kept
saying that my husband was an idiot. Acknowledged that me and
my husband were fighting about his gambling addiction. still
put stake chests by him, still tried to bait him, would put chests
down, and then when my husband would close by would get rid of
was close by would get rid of them or move them, was sort of
repeatedly boasting about how his money made him better than
everyone. And so I thought, you know what would kill this guy?
If the man who he's calling a loser and beneath him could get
what he has,
that would kill him. And you know what? It's I actually have
some information on this particular thing and it's that my husband
three years ago had with your girlfriend when he had nothing
when he wasn't when he didn't even have a mattress in his room.
So So what is so what is all your millions worth really? So what
is it all worth really? Flash forward. People are very mad. Thank
you for the follow. People are very mad. I'm trying to word carefully
because I know that even though there aren't a lot of people
watching right now, this will get clipped and I know that I am
an extension of my husband and so I have to behave. Who's mad
for what? And everyone was like, this is the take. This is what
I think the take is. It does not matter that Kimmy has had sex
with other people than Paul. We are all adults. None of us has
had sex with with even with just one person. Not one person in
this scenario has had sex with just our partner. But I knew it
would really hurt Ice Poseidon because of who he is and because
of his ego to say it. I did not think it was that big of a deal.
I thought he'd get a huge ego hit and then be like, "Okay, whatever.
I'm just going to I'm going to choke I I thought he was going
to choke up. I thought I was going to It was a gotcha moment."
And yes, I do think Kimmy's a That's okay. That's okay. I wouldn't
even have with my husband when he was living like that. And I
didn't. I made him wait for 2 years. But if that's her gig, do
your thing. And Ice just has to love her through it. My husband
is a My husband is a huge and I love him through it. And I love
him through it. Here's why I did not care to use Kimmy. And this
is why I didn't care that Kimmy was collateral. Kimmy is the
weirdest [__] I've ever met in my life. Let me bring
you back 3 years. Let me bring you back 3 years. I joined Twitch.
I blow up. I'm already in a relationship while I'm on Twitch
with my ex-husband. I meet Tim on a John Zurka Royale. At this
point, he already knew Kimmy. I think they had met a couple weeks
or a month or couple months prior. They had not met in person
yet. They had not done anything in person yet. I don't even think
they were actually even flirting much at this point. When me
and Tim meet, Ominous Thunder. Yes. When me and Tim meet, immediate
spark. Immediate spark. I think that everyone could tell on the
live stream that there was something there. At the at that point,
I was in a monogous relationship with someone else, but it turned
my world upside down. My relationship then became open from that
point on. I did not meet Tim at this point because of who he
was with his life in his life. Tim kept telling me, "Come out.
Come out. Come out." He kept saying, "Fly yourself to me." I
said, "You're not even going to fly me out?" Yeah. No, I'm not.
If you don't even have enough money to fly me out. No, I'm not
coming to see you. No. Come out. Come out. Come out. Oh my god.
The thunder is so scary. The thunder is so scary. Free spins.
Shut up. I said, "No, there's under no circumstances is am I
coming to you?" But I did feel something. I did feel something.
So I said, "Listen, we can What does this have to do with Kimmy,
though? Burner, just you wait. Burner, just you wait." Because
the second I said, "Tim, I just want to be friends." Tim, I just
want to be friends. Guess who rents a U-Haul? Guess who rents
a U-Haul? And guess who posts about the U-Haul trip on his story
so that I could see it. Guess I'll give you three guesses. Daniel,
you are absolutely correct. It was Tim. It was Tim. Yeah. Guess
who then for weeks afterwards while he was [__] her
would talk about me and ask where I was on live streams and say
that we should fight each other on live streams. I'll give you
another guess who it was. It was Tim. It was Tim. I at this point
me and Tim were broken up. We did not have a relationship. We
knew that there was a spark there, but we could not go there.
I was in a relationship with someone else. He was also literally
in a relationship with someone else back at home. Had was talking
to his whole roster. I was not involved. I was in a different
state. Had never met up with him. All I knew is that we had I
had several phone calls with someone who
I thought that I had very strong chemistry with, very strong
feelings for in a little amount of time. And it scared me a lot.
And I got cold feet and I didn't want to do anything. I didn't
want to change my life, especially, and I wasn't about to go
blow up my life for a man who didn't even have a mattress in
his room. So, Tim and Kimmy commenced
their relationship. I was not involved whatsoever, besides the
occasional Tim trying to bring me into it by trying desperately
to pin me me and Kimmy against each other, of which we never
did, by the way. Let me be so clear. There was never any beef
with me and Kimmy. Literally ever. Where's the Giga Chad emote?
Tim, get out of here. There was literally never beef between
me and Kimmy. In fact, and this is why, and this is this is not,
okay, this is why I'm the only the first interaction I had with
Kimmy, even while Tim was trying to sew destruction between us.
Is this a Tim expose story or a scavenger hunt story? I'm giving
you background. I'm giving you background on why I did not care
that Kimmy was collateral and why I don't care about her feelings
of when I leaked the information to Ice to hurt him. I'm I'm
telling you why I do not care about Kimmy and why I think she's
a psycho [__] Sorry, I would never use a word like
I'm a girl's girl. Um, why she's a little off her rocker and
weird. Why she's a little weird. Where was I in the story? Holy
[__] I feel like most of us knew about this stuff.
I don't know. Lol. Fair enough. Yes, because Tim made it extremely
public.
Tim made it extremely public. And Tim made our Tim made his relationship
with me so public that I had to stop talking to him because I
was like, you are going to get me in trouble. I have a relationship.
And so I had to leave. Why'd you delete the 10 bods from earlier
today? Because my internet was cutting out so bad. I just wanted
to save the story, interact, and then leave. You just wanted
to hurt Kim. Let's be real. I'm not done with the story. Okay.
Kimmy had text me while me and Tim weren't even talking anymore.
They had their relationship. I guess it lasted a few months and
then they just stopped on their own. It wasn't Someone said that
I stole Tim from Kimmy. I didn't. Their relationship ran its
course before she even got back with Tim. They stopped sleeping
with each other for months and months before. is what I know
is what Tim has told me and what I understand to be the truth.
Their relationship ran its course without any involvement from
anyone else. Again, I was with someone else. This is its own
thing that I was not privy to. This story gets so weird. What
I'm having drama with a streamer named Destiny. You might have
heard of him. Kimmy texts me and is like, "I just want to let
you Extremely sweet was extremely sweet and was like, oh, I just
want to let you know like keep your head up, you know. Uh, I'm
sorry that you're getting as much hate as you are. Just like
a very sweet message. I don't remember responding or not because
I was getting so much hate that I just went offline. Anyway,
that was the extent of my interactions with Kimmy up until Dream
Hack of this year. When I got together with Tim last year, Dom,
thank you. When I got together with Tim last year, him and Kimmy
were still friends. There was no weird relationship with each
other. They still texted once in a while about normal stuff like
like Tim messaged her to like not kill herself when she got her
nose job. Um
Kimmy had whatever. Kimmy had also texted him and this goes into
the story at a later date. Kimmy had also texted him why I it's
not fair that I don't get to move in and I'll tell you about
the story about that later. I'm getting so convoluted in this
story because it gets so weird. Um okay at DreamHack Kimmy's
there. There's I'm thinking nothing of it. I've been in multiple
situations at this point where I have to be around women that
Tim has had sex with or that Tim has had a thing with at this
point. She was not the only one there. She was not the only one
at Dream Hack that Tim had had a relationship with. There was
no I, you know, I'm an adult. He's an adult. It's not I was not
looking to start a fight. Everyone else is being really friendly
and Kimmy keeps making weird faces at both of us. doesn't come
up to introduce Tim, which at this point is weird because they're
friends. There there's nothing there's they're they're friends.
Like there's nothing weird happening. So Tim is like, "That's
weird that she didn't come up to me." She keeps giving me weird
looks.
Yes, she keeps giving me weird looks. Esho, who's in chat right
now, made a bad joke about Kimmy's nose or whatever. So, she's
going psycho about that, too. She's She has her own [__]
to deal with. So, I'm thinking maybe it's not me. There's no
reality in which I'm thinking me and Kimmy have beef right now.
me and Kim are going to fight. What I did think was, "Oh, maybe
she thinks that I'm weird because I know that they used to have
a relationship, so I should go up to her and I should be the
first one to extend myself as like, hey, I'm Leah, whatever."
So, I go up to Kimmy at Dream Hack and I'm like, "Hey, I'm Leah.
I wanted to formally introduce myself because I'm like, "Oh,
maybe she's giving me dirty looks and didn't come up to Tim because
she thinks that I'm weird or something." I go up to her and I'm
like, "Hi, I'm Leah. I wanted to formally meet you and um and
say hello. I just wanted to let you know that I haven't forgotten
about that message you sent me about um Destiny and the Destiny
drama 2 3 years ago. It meant a lot to me and you're I wanted
to let you know that uh it was a very sweet message and you didn't
have to do that. And she first of all I'm looking up at her saying
this because I'm 51 and she's 611. She's like a WNBA player and
I'm a rat in like he in high heel high heel shoes looking up
at her and she looks down at me and is like okay and huh I'm
immediately I'm like what is going Immediately I'm like what's
going on? Immediately I'm like what's going on? But then I'm
like oh this isn't me. This has got to be the Echrio thing. So
she's like okay and and then I'm like anxiety talking like and
I don't think Echo uh I'm literally doing it. This Kimmy is above
me right now. I'm literally I'm Estrio I don't think meant it.
I I'm sorry that you saw that. Like there's nothing like nobody
thinks there's anything wrong with your nose. You still you're
still beautiful. Whatever. Estrokes strays in the chat. Yeah,
he is. Cuz he's the reason. He's the reason for all of this.
And she gets really defensive. So I'm like, "Okay, that was the
wrong move." Also, I'm in a minefield in this conversation. I'm
literally in a minefield in this conversation. I'm like, "Okay,
I keep making wrong moves." She gets defensive and like, "I don't
even care. It's just I didn't even care about it. But I just
I thought me and him were friends and I'm like, "Okay, well,
I'm sure that you guys still are friends. He makes jokes with
me all the time. He calls me a all the time." You know, I make
fun of him for being black and I didn't say that, but I think
I did say uh he calls me a all the time. Like I'm sure he said
something about the way that I look. Like I think that you know,
you can't give it credence. I I I think I said something like,
you know, you can't he didn't mean it. Something like that. I'm
like, but I'm like anxiety talking too, so I'm like I'm missing
everything. I'm It's probably not coming out completely the same
way that I'm remembering it. Uh because I'm just so anxious that
she's like looking at me like this. Um
and then I go to like and then I end the conversation by like
touching her arm like a grief counselor at a funeral home. like
I'm so sorry that for your loss, but I'm like I'm trying to extend
that really there is no beef and I and I am want to be friends
with you and we're going to be seeing each other and I don't
care that you had with my husband and the past is the past. We're
adults, right? And so I like I'm like it was so nice meeting
you. She like flips her hair and turns around and is like super
weird and I immediately and this is on stream. I immediately
go back to Tim and I'm like, "That was the weirdest interaction
I've ever had in my life."
And
then the rest of the weekend, she is still super weird towards
me and looking at me weird and whatever. A month before that,
Kimmy texted Tim saying, "It's not fair that I don't get to move
in. It's not fair that I don't get to move in." And I was like,
"What is this about?" And Tim was like, and I knew this before
she knew this. Tim was like, "I
had to lie to Kimmy that I still had feelings for her." so that
she did not move in because Kiana did not want to tell her that
she was the reason. Cutebot did not want to tell her that she
was the reason she couldn't move in. And he showed me the proof
for it and everything. Like I'm not, this isn't me believing
my husband at face value. He showed me the text messages between
him and Cutebot like orchestrating this whole thing. Like it's
not orchestrating the whole thing. And we've posted those as
well. We've posted those as well. Um I did not take him for face
value. There's many points in this where I have not believed
the things that Tim has told me. um but where I've had to seek
evidence for what actually happened. So, I'm giving you an a
measured response. I'm not giving you what Tim has told me. Um
because Tim's also a liar. He hid gambling from from me for months.
Um but he [__] this cute butt individual to. No,
from what I know. Hopefully not. It would one of a what a hundred
e girls that he's
add another one to the list. See if I give a [__]
Anyway, so then oh months pass and and that's not a thing. I'm
like, "Okay, whatever. I don't care that you lied or or I don't
care that you lied to her. I don't care it." I'm like, in my
mind, I'm like, "Okay, whatever. This is just not my business."
She's moved on. She's with Paul at this point. Tim and I are
getting married, so it's like not it's not a thing. Then a month
after Dream Hack, Ice like threatens to kill her or something.
Ice threatens to kill her and and while Tim is going over the
drama on stream, Sam Pepper joins his Discord and is like, "Release
the love letters. release the love letters in uh in his chat
and is like now is the the perfect time for drama. Now's the
perfect time for drama and Tim's like oh god. So I'm thinking
I'm thinking oh everyone knows they had and also there are love
letters. So Tim has lied to me about the severity of their relationship
which he didn't need to. So I before he can even come home I'm
do I message her. I'm like what have you told Paul? I'm like
what have you told Paul what was the significance of this relationship?
And this isn't ending. this wouldn't be relationship ending for
me and Tim. I just at this point I was like, "Oh, did he why
why would Tim lie to me about about his relationship with Kimmy?"
Turns out he didn't. The love letter situation was I think about
base ghost, but Sam Pepper got confused and thought that it was
Well, this is what I There's two possible realities. One, Sam
Pepper thought that Tim was base ghost. Two, Kimmy is making
this up and just being evil and extremely weird. They're both
extremely plausible. So, at this point, Kimmy says to me, "No,
the the the relationship was not significant. There was nothing
there. It was like it was an adult relationship, whatever." Like,
I've told Paul everything. But then she sends me this four page,
four paragraph message, outof control psychosis.
Out of control psychosis about I'm the reason he didn't text
her anymore. Paul's so mad at Tim for talking about her nose
job, for talking about their their um Paul's really really mad
at Tim for talking about their relationship on stream. And I'm
like, "Okay, do you think that there's a do you think he's going
to like leak that you guys had because I'm trying to have a baby
and I'd like to get ahead of this. Like if he has to make a statement,
he like we'd like to make a statement about this." And she's
like, "No, no, no, no, no. and you should and you should watch
what you say because Sam and and Paul have nothing to lose. So
if you bother them, they could leak it. So I'm like, "Okay, what?"
Like, but during this, I'm like, I tell her the reason because
I think she deserves to hear it because I don't like triangulation.
I don't like uh when I don't like when people can't communicate
with each other their real feelings. So I go I tell her, "Kimmy,
the reason he hasn't texted you is not because of me. It is because
Kiana cutebot did not know how to tell you that she did not want
you to live in the house. It's she doesn't hate you. There's
no drama. She just didn't know you were in a fragile state after
your nose job. She didn't want she didn't know how to tell you
that she didn't want to move in with you. I was very very open
about like she not about that she hates you. Whatever. So then
Kimmy goes to Kiana and is like Lav told me this. Is it true?
And Kiana texts Tim and is really really mad at Tim. Kiana starts
getting really and this is where Cupbot starts being a weirdo.
Turbo weirdo. Cupot gots really really mad at Tim and is like
what the [__] is your problem? Why would you tell
her that? And I was like and Tim tried to tell her the only reason
why Leah told her that is because she said that she had the narrative
wrong and I didn't want to lie anymore and why would I lie anymore?
So then Kiana asks, "Can I just tell Kimmy that you lied to Leah?
You are so weird. You are so weird. That is the weird like because
I don't want to be honest about because I don't want to be honest
about why the small issue I have with my friend, I'm going to
like do this weird power play." Very weird. So then Kiana starts
getting really mad at Tim their relationship. These names are
so irrelevant. Holy. No, they will come back. They will come
back. I see why you said the story gets weird and confusing.
Holy yes, because Cutebot started being really, really weird.
So then after this, after I know what she after I'm getting the
narrative from Sam Pepper that Tim wrote love letters, I'm like,
Tim, I want to go back in your messages. I go back into his messages
with with Kimmy.
Nothing. Nothing even remotely romantic between them for years.
For years. I saw things that were like, "Come into my room, like
sneak into my room." Yes, they were having sex, but there was
no They were talking to each other about Kimmy was talking to
Tim about Paul. Tim was talking to Kimmy about me, about his
girlfriend back at home. Like, there were it was they were friends.
It was completely friendly conversation. Kimmy wasn't obsessed
with Tim, which is why this is so confusing.
What I don't understand. It did not seem like in their messages
she had strong feelings for him. So, I don't know why she's obsessed
with trying to insert herself and trying to ego me in our relationship.
There was nothing.
The most the most emotionally
poignant conversation is when Kimmy was stressed about her job
and career and money and she was like
baiting Tim and Tim was like no don't. And that the conversation
ended there like it wasn't that was like the only Is it possible
that Kiana panicked and she was operating out of fear and anxiety
rather than malice? Ye uh yes at that point which there was no
beef at that point. Now is different and I'll get to that in
a second. But yeah, their relationship was extremely I and then
I learned that like there like there was no love letter and they
were both being honest with me. Kimmy had told me that there
was there was no significant relationship. Tim had told me there
was no significant relationship. He let me go through all their
messages and there was nothing. He had never lied to me. It was
what what it was. We've all as adults, if you [__]
if you're someone who is normal, um have had relationships where
you have sex with a friend. Like that is an extremely normal
thing to do. And it ran its course. I don't even think that Tim
lived there for most of the month. I think it was like for a
couple months. And Tim will tell that story, I guess, on his
on his own on his stream maybe later today. I don't I don't care.
I don't care about it. Why did I say you [__] a dog?
Because I did. Thank you guys for
the follows. You knew it was a bad thing. That's why you kept
it a secret. No, I knew that him and Kimmy had had sex with each
other when they did it. the first time that they did it because
he threw it in my face to make me jealous because he he
only had sex with her because I said that I would not leave my
boyfriend. Anyway, this is a this is a this is this was earlier
in the conversation. Oh my god. How do I turn off these notifications?
How do I turn off these Okay. Okay. Let me bring chat back up
again. No, I did not actually have to the dog. Oh my god. Where
does the story go now? Oh, so me and Tim or me and Kimmy have
uh we're in the same space. We know the same people. I hear things
through the right. I hear things that Kimmy is saying about my
relationship with my husband, about how I was the second choice.
I don't know why she was doing this at the time. I didn't care
about it at the I mean, I still I still don't care about this.
I still don't care about this. It's obviously not true. Oh my
god. Now this I sucked off a dog things. Oh my god. Oh my god.
I shouldn't have made that joke. I shouldn't have made that joke.
I shouldn't have made that joke. I should have made that joke.
League of Goons. Fat Chad. Oh my god. You were known as a racist.
That's true. Focus, focus, focus. I forgot where I was in the
story. I forgot where I was in the story. Do you guys remember?
Oh, yeah. She was talking about me being the second choice. This
wasn't a big deal to me, but obviously at some point her and
Cutebot started talking about me or whatever. And now they've
ran with this narrative that I'm deeply insecure and that I've
started something with Kimmy. I have Tim has had multiple relationships
in this space. He's been online for a long time. There is no
shortage of women who he has either had sex with in this space
or had a thing with. In fact, there are more that he has than
he hasn't. I have had nothing but normal friendly relationships
with all of them. Friendly if not friends. I literally I texted
one of them this morning was like, "Thank you so much. I It's
a It's an honor to be Eskimo sisters with you. Thank you for
never doing anything weird. Thank you for just being normal and
sweet and whatever. I don't understand this narrative at all.
I don't know why Kimmy then went on Well, this is why this is
why I did not care that Kimmy was collateral is because she does
weird [__] like this. Because she does weird ego
power playing like this. She controls her friends around her.
She controls people around her. Oh my god, I'm making I'm giving
a a slow mode on chat. This is insane. 45 seconds. Yeah. Hope
you like that. Hope you like that, guys. Hope you like that.
45 second wait. Yeah, take it. Mommy says you're in timeout.
Mommy says you need to behave. So, um, what was I saying? Now
I can focus more. Yeah, there's been no beef in between me and
Kimmy except for the beef that she's created. Uh, I don't know
why she messaged me that long message saying that I was the reason
why Tim didn't text her even though he was texting her.
I don't know why two day three days ago she wrote this long message.
I don't even I don't even have it anymore. If someone wants to
send it to me, I can go over it because I thought it was funny
where she was saying that I was the most insecure person in the
world. The two saying I'm insecure are the are have the most
plastic surgery you have ever you can ever imagine. Two with
the most plastic surgery on their whole body saying exactly to
each other. Um
I
listen I don't that's not how I operate. Tim Dick game must be
good if she's still texting him. Tim like when we met. There
is no way. There is no way that Tim was giving was laying the
hammer down to the point where Kimmy would still act this crazy
towards me and why she would still try to ego me at this point.
What she said I thought was very the fact that she's still desperately
trying to insert herself in my relationship. In the long message
she had posted the other day, she brought up something that Kiana
Cutebot had told her, which is that Tim's mom asked about her
at the wedding. Oh, where's Kimmy? She's so nice. And then she
Kimmy weaponized that to ego me to give herself
power over me at my wedding. Like, what? You're so weird. I don't
You are such a not Why are you trying to put yourself in our
relationship, youo?
Why are you so obsessed with my husband? It's big. It's big,
but it's not that big. It's not that big. So, I don't get it.
I don't know why Kiana's going turbo weirdo mode and giving her
information like that. The only reason why Tim's mom asked where
Kimmy was is because she was the only roommate that wasn't there
and she had no idea that they had. The relationship was so insignificant
that Tim met her and did not know that they were seeing each
other at all. She just thought that they were roommates and that
she wasn't there. The pretty blonde girl who was roommates with
Tim wasn't there. Where was she? Why are you bringing that up
to try to ego me at the wedding? You weirdo. You're in a relationship.
If I If I was in her shoes and I was trying to get back with
Paul, why would I act like I Why would I act like I cared about
this person's relationship? It's like the strangest thing ever.
Girth is important. Girth is important. Kimmy gonna expose Tim's
love letters. I I hope I hope that she does. I hope that she
does. Did you see Dian saying that you need to kiss Kimmy's uh
feet? No. Show receipts or you're wasting our time. I have showed
receipts. What do you want receipts of? We've posted all the
receipts in Tim's Discord, Goon Squad. The receipts of of Kiana
saying to lie to Kimmy about still having feelings, Tim saying
he didn't want to lie to her anymore, and Kiana getting mad and
saying, "Can I tell Kimmy that you lied to Leah instead?" Those
are all posted, which is why she's upset. She's the only person
or what? The only people. She's the only people besides family.
Her jaw were the only people who came to our wedding besides
family. So, of course, Kimmy heard that from Kiana. I'm not going
to talk about who told me that Kimmy was talking about me because
I don't want them to get in trouble. But I posted the messages
between me and Kimmy, how psycho she was towards me. I just sent
your your parents a video of you. There's no video, guys. There's
no there's no video. It's not real. I started that rumor about
myself literally to sell on only Only Fans. There's not It's
not real. Kimmy said Tim wrote he will die without her that he
is madly in love.
This doesn't exist. This doesn't exist. I need you. I want you
to go on twitch.com right now. Goonzilla. Guili
L. On that This is live. Yes. You will see every single clip
about him trying to rez women by saying he wants to get them
pregnant, marry them.
He talked to every woman this way. I'm sure he said things like
that to Kimmy. I'm sure he said things like that to Kimmy. Nobody
not stupid believes them. Nobody not stupid believes those things.
I think what Kimmy strikes me as is someone who is extremely
insecure and desperate to be significant. I think the idea that
Tim was able to move on with me, someone who he held over her
head probably, who she knew was using her to to get to me, I
think gave her a thing about me. And I think it's why
she is obsessed with posturing herself above me, even while she's
in a relationship. I don't think that she even still has feelings
for Tim. I just think that she is so terrified that she is not
significant to someone. And maybe that comes from somewhere.
She's not significant to us. I wanted to be her friend. I tried
to be her friend. I tried to be normal with her. And she has
tried so
hard to not be normal. Why did Tim fire a ring then? Guys, that
the real question is why hasn't Paul? After 10 years, Paul doesn't
want you. After 10 years, you know, babe, after 10 years, you
know. Get out. No time. Now, are the allegations surrounding
you and Destiny true? No. I never had sex with Destiny ever.
She also said that and she knows that I didn't have with Destiny
either. She knows. She's like she's so desperate and like flailing.
She's like just trying to do anything. Paul will probably get
back with her. Who'd you meet Goon through? John Zirka. If you
had Dusty that actually make you cooler. I didn't I did not have
I'm not really in the habit of um letting men enter me with their
who I'm not in a relationship with. It's not really my thing.
You're even worse than Kimmy. Stop playing good girl. At what
point did you think I was playing good girl here? Like at what
point? I The whole this is like evil. Weren't you a hooker? No,
I was a shooker baby when I was in a relationship with two people.
I wasn't a street hooker.
Kimmy is done. She's done for She's gone for good. I doubt it.
I I don't even think it's that big of a deal that her and Tim
had I what I think is very weird is her obsession with me and
Tim's relationship and trying to insert herself in it. I just
don't get it. She's There's women who have been in relationships
with Tim for much longer duration that he's told me he was genuinely
in love with, who have been nothing but normal to me, haven't
reached out, haven't been mean to me, haven't done anything.
I don't know why this one person is trying to do that. She wishes
she was getting married. That's why she should. She She still
can. Like probably not to Paul. She's super obsessed. She's streaming
about it. Wait, that's you. She There's nothing for her to say
about this. She's caught. Like there's no What is there to say?
What could she possibly say? Does Does Kimmy come off as lequacious
to you? Does Kimmy come off as articulate and loquacious to you?
She c she could not keep up with me in a conversation like this.
I would invite her to talk with me on a conversation like this.
She's not she is only able to do like surface level primal instinct
lying to protect herself and to and to keep insecurity to keep
her insecurity fed. She's not capable of like doing anything
else. She is more conventionally pretty than you. That could
be true. Tim has had sex with women who are literally models
who are who are literally like magazine models. I It is what
it is. I have never The reason why Tim loves me is not If you
are with someone because you think that they're going to look
like that forever, you're not going to be very happy. I have
always more than being beautiful, which I do think I am, not
toot my own horn, I always have thought that I
my calling card was that I was smart and funny. how he pull any
of you tbh. Yeah, I don't know. But I have never I've always
cared more about Now, if someone was smarter and funnier than
me, I'd be maybe a little more insecure, but I'm The people who
go for Kimmy are not people who go for me, and the people who
go for me are not people who go for Kimmy. I think I think most
men would would have sex with either of us, but I don't think
that like the same type of men who want to marry people like
me are not going to be with Kimmy and vice versa. So only ugly
want to have sex with me. Diva, I'm sure that that's not true.
I'm sure that's not true. I mean, your husband went for both
of you. My husband quested for two years for me before I finally
gave in. Kimmy had sex with him the first time they were alone.
Men will have sex with anything that's easy. I hate to talk about
a girl like this, but that is like what is true. That's what
is true. A man will literally have with anyone who makes it easy.
You don't have to have skill. You don't have to make him laugh.
You don't even have to
as long as you are a [__] You're going to say your
interaction with cute bot is now um yeah, she's weird. She's
like feeding Kimmy information to like keep her insecure, to
keep her thinking that like she's like the fact that Kean even
told Kimmy that Tim's mom asked about her at the wedding for
like ammunition towards me. Like what are you doing? Why are
you doing this to Kimmy? Why are you doing this to anyone? And
then Kiana texted Tim two nights ago after calling me toxic.
Uh, okay.
and and uh and and saying that Tim had a new owner and she didn't
own him anymore. Okay. Uh that she wasn't mad at him anymore
and if he behaved, he could come back in the group chat. And
Tim was like, "No, you were weird towards my wife. Like, why
would I still be friends with you after doing this to me?" Kiana's
weird. I don't understand what is going on. I texted Kiana and
was just like, "Hey, I really hate triangulation. I think we
would have been great friends if we got to like hang out with
each other. I don't know why you're being weird towards me. Don't
know what problem you have with me. And she just messaged back
Jesus Christ, which I'm like, okay, you win. You care the least.
You win. You care the least. Did Kimmy lie to ice? She maintain
she didn't lie at all. I have no idea. She I She told me and
Tim that that he did not know or that he did know. Sorry. That
he did know. I'm burning all his bridges. No, I'm not. I have
if him and Kiana wanted to be friends still, I would be very
There's things I know about Kiana that I am not saying. Um I
want that bridge to be there. I don't know why she's being weird.
I've tried to reach out and make it not weird. She obviously
is not interested in having any sort of helpful or useful confrontation,
but I of course want them to still be friends. That's why I invited
her to our wedding. Like that's I wanted them to be there. I
was so grateful that they could be there. It's so weird that
she did that. Um,
is your husband going to have to get a real job now? No, I'm
going to take I'm going to take care of him forever. How many
laboplasties have you had? I think laboplasties are genuinely
evil. And I cannot imagine anything more embarrassing than having
a ch and humiliating than than giving birth to a child out of
a mutilated vagina.
Um, that's the feminist in me. I would never get plastic surgery.
I would get Botox. I would get filler. But I would never get
plastic surgery ever, ever, ever. I think it is a horrible standard
to set. I if you do it, that's your thing. I would never get
it and I would never tell any of my friends to get it and I would
advise them against it. You afraid of Kiana? I'm not afraid of
her. I just don't I I have no reason to. I want them to be friends.
So Twitch and Twitch culture is hell on earth. Yeah. Yep. Why
did you hook up with Destiny while you were married? I was in
an open relationship. I was in a very publicly open relationship.
That's another thing I don't understand that Kimmy tried to throw
at me was that I cheated and it just isn't true. Everyone knows
it's not true. It was very public. Isn't Tim mutilated? No. Tim
actually has the perfect circumcision. You are if you don't realize
Timmy and Kim are still speaking. I literally have never had
a problem with them talking ever. He has texted her to offer
support when she was while we were together.
Don't have an issue with that at all. Don't have an issue with
him talking to anyone he's been with. I still someone that I
had a relationship with helped us for the scavenger hunt. Like
I we are adult people. We are literally adult people. This is
not something I care about. Tim's vagina is perfect. That's true.
Yeah. They can be friends. They were friends forever. Forever.
They did had no drama between each other. That's why this is
so strange. There was no like they didn't have a big breakup.
They literally just stopped hooking up because it was uninteresting
to both of them. They didn't get back with people, but like I
don't think Kimmy got back with Paul for like months after they
stopped hooking up. Tim didn't get wasn't with anyone for months
after that. There was no They just ended completely amicably.
Actually, I think that Kimmy was trying to date Mitch Jones is
what I besidon said a couple days ago. though. Maybe that is
why she stopped hooking up with Tim. Mitch Jones, magnet of Twitch
hosts, you do come off as very mature and intelligent actually.
Well, thank you. What lip filler technique do you get to get
your upper middle lip like that? The Russian technique,
but this is also overdrawn a little bit. So, now that we have
all the context, can we get back to where things stand now? Uh,
yeah. Kimmy's desperately trying to still posture herself over
me even though she's in a relationship with someone else. I She's
like still trying to state claim to Tim.
Don't know why.
I wish she would stop. I mean, I don't even care if she does
stop. It's It just doesn't look good for her with Ice. If I was
Ice, I'd be like, "Why is my girlfriend still trying to be significant
to someone she had sex with? They It's been four years."
Like, I don't It's just It's weird. Um, I if Ice didn't know,
that super sucks. That sucks really bad. But of course, I don't
think any man wants to hear that something that they had to get
millions of dollars for, the same woman was giving it up to someone
with nothing for free. I think that that does a lot to a man's
ego. So, I think that would really suck. Which is Ice's friends
knew about Kimmy. Um, I think just Sam and and Hannah and all
of her girlfriends. Would you let Kimmy be a sister wife? I've
said this. If Kimmy learns how to cook and clean and gets on
some meds, we could be a genuinely beautiful family. I'm willing
to share the load, literally, and of chores.
And um she we will get her room for her if she needs one. She
just needs to be less weird. So, are they still together? It
sounds like it. Tim insists he only knew about the love letter
and only assumed that they banged. Um, so we actually saw a video
someone posted a video in Tim's Discord where they're talking
about a love letter and I think Sam Pepper thought that Tim was
base ghost. Uh, and I didn't I don't think that they realized
that Kimmy had had many relationships with other men while her
and Paul were broking up broken up. So I think that they got
a little confused on who Tim was. But Tim and her relationship
was just friends who had Every single person has had that relationship
before. Yeah, it was odd that Ice was saying he's 5 foot. I don't
think Goon is 5 foot. No, Tim is 6 foot. He's like a He's a tall
guy. He's not extremely tall, but he's definitely a tall guy.
Do you think it's weird your girlfriend is living in a totally
different state despite being together for 5 years? Yeah, that
is extremely weird. I mean, Kimmy does not come off now. I'm
putting aside my personal proximity to this to just chat about
this generally. When you read messages between him and her, it
reads like they're 13 years old and it's extremely formal. I
don't think part of why I'm not worried about her and Tim is
because I'm almost positive Kimmy is not capable of having a
close relationship with someone. Does that make sense? I don't
think um she's exceptionally
emotionally
intelligent or connected. If she's been with someone for 10 years
and she's talking to him like that, I'm not worried about the
3 months she spent with my husband. Do you think Kimmy and Ice's
relationship is purely transactional and involves no love? I
think that if you value things like money and status, which I
know Ice does, you are going to attract women who value the same
things. I think that if you're with someone for that long, there's
a level of cohabitance. Well, they're not even co cohabitating,
so I don't know. There's a level of comfortableness and familiarity
that you get used to. So, there's obviously love there, but I
don't think it's that serious. Kim went through a hoe phase.
Now, she's ready to settle down. The leoplasty signifies a fresh
start. Maybe I see that you guys are chatting. I don't want to
super dignify it. I listen, I'm I'm not trying to denigrate
Kimmy into the ground. I I think I won already. I don't I don't
feel like I need to hammer it in. Um I'm trying to be very kind
with my wording. One thing that really pissed me off is is how
Tim's old roommates have believed this narrative about about
it that Cutebot has started and tried to make a thing even though
that they know that I'm not weird towards his exes and that I'm
extremely normal and that I have been and can be around people
who Tim has had relationships with. So, I don't know what they're
doing. I don't know what they're doing. I think that one thing
that is happening and why people are so upset with me about this
is that they think that Kimmy is a child and that she should
face no consequences for I had no loyalty to Kimmy. I had no
loyalty to Kimmy. Kimmy's been nothing but a to me. And if I'm
trying to embarrass and humiliate her hus or her boyfriend, sorry,
not husband. If I'm trying to humiliate her boyfriend, why would
I not use Kimmy as collateral? She's done nothing but be an awful
to me. But the people rallying around her are like, "No, she
doesn't. She doesn't know any better. Stop. She's a She's 30.
She's a She's older than me. She's 3 years older than me. She's
30 years old. If you want to poke the bear, I'll show you how
it roars. Like, I don't Somebody should have saved her and told
her not to start beef with me. I People know who I am online.
Do not with me. I will use any means necessary. I a ruthless
[__] Like I don't Why would you step to me? You know
who I am. You know who I am. Hello. Anyone who loves you. If
Cutebot really cared about her, she would not have armed her
with something about me. She would have been like, "Just lay
low, babe." It's like, you think Kimmy would kick your ass? I
know Kimmy could kick my ass. She's 6' tall,
muscular shoulders and arms. I am 51, made of dough. So, do you
think part of why Ice likes Kimmy is the fact that she's child
childish and easy to manipulate. I don't know. She's pretty.
I think he likes her because she's pretty. I I think that a lot
I think that men will put up with so many red flags because they
are attracted to someone. So, I don't know. I actually think
he's I there's a clip where he's yelling at her that's being
tossed around where he says that she's not capable of helping
him or capable of emotionally being there when he needs it. And
uh yeah, I I think that to some extent you are lay you're making
your own bed when you enter a relationship with someone like
Kimmy where you know that they cannot that they don't have the
tools to be helpful to you or to be an asset to you. But she's
pretty. But no amount of pinning up her face over the next 60
years are going to change her usefulness. So and he'll learn
that if they stay together. I don't know. I don't know. You could
cut your nose off, cut your labia off, get nipped and tucked
a billion times and it's still going to be you underneath. So
Kimmy said on Discord she's holding in her side of the story.
She in what side? She's told everyone a different story. Deathly
Ill was just in there the other day saying that Kimmy rejected
Tim. Kimmy has told every single person a different version of
the story. Which side is she holding? Which side is she holding?
All eight of them. Huh?
She and Ice are going to change the story and say you lied about
everything. What? Better you post all DM evidence on Twitter.
Oh, you're trying to bait me to post stuff. It's already in Goon
Squad. Join discord.com/gwns
k w a w Goon Squad. It's Tim's Discord. All of the all of the
screen recordings and proof has been in there about about them.
And then if you want to know the nature of their relationship,
there are clips all over Tim. It was very public. It clips all
over Tim's thing about when we first met, when they first met.
All public. She said she's going to expose you soon. You'll be
begging for mercy. Is that true? Ice was enjoying the You ruined
it for him. You know what's crazy is that I think that Ice Poseidon
does get a like excited about a smart or combative woman. I I
saw him talking to Grace Thorp, who is pretty, but she's not
like she's not she doesn't look like Kimmy. She doesn't look
like blonde and tall. She's beautiful still though. But she was
argumentative and quickwitted and Ice was like excited and happy
and like in it. You know what I mean? And I've just like Paul,
why are you still with her? You're you wasted. And this is why
I think Paul's evil is you wasted 10 years of her life no not
knowing if you wanted her or not. She should have cheated on
you. She should have cheated on you. Literally set her free.
Let her find someone who's going to take care of her. Kimmy is
going to slime you out for up her bag. Well, is Grace Thorp not
blonde and tall? She is tall, but I don't She's not I guess she
is blonde now. I forgot because she used to have brown hair,
but she doesn't look like an EA girl. She like looks like just
a normal beautiful girl. Bro gets mentally stimulated with Lety
Hannah amaranth grace. Yeah, this is another thing like I another
thing what I don't understand is why Kimmy is trying to start
this narrative about me being insecure when like your your boyfriend
has publicly humiliated you for for trying to cut out other women.
I That is not my history. I'm friends with Tim's exes. I'm very
friendly with Tim's exes. There is no beef between me and even
one of them except for you. And you tried to ruin Maddiey's life
because he messaged her. And then her and Cupbot are looking
at each other two [__] with the most plastic surgery
you have ever seen saying exactly to each other. Talking about
my insecurity. What the [__] Am I in the upside down?
Am I Am I in the upside down? Kimmy tried to ruin Mattiey's life,
dude. And not just her. Kimmy has called on the phone almost
every woman in the space to be like, "You're not my real friend.
Ice is messaging you because he does. He messages everyone and
he's a scumbag. I don't like him either. I think he deserves
everything and worse." And she tried to get Maddie removed from
every stream ever, not just with Paul. But she was trying to
politic with other people too. And she was telling Tim about
it as they were [__] This is how non-serious the
relationship was. They would literally like literally while they
were Kimmy would be like, "I still want to get back with Paul.
I think she's seeing I think he's seeing someone else. I'm gonna
make sure that he's that she's nowhere." And Tim would be like,
"Okay, thank you for the easy vagina."
That's the only like how Kimmy What is going on?
See,
stop being f stop being friends with people who feed you more
drama. Yes, Kimmy's 30 and she's still beautiful. She could meet
someone so easily that wants to take care of her so easily. Talk
more about the Maddie and Kimmy drama. Kimmy said that's fake
news. That is hilarious. And it's not just her by a long shot.
It's not just Maddie by a long shot. By a long shot. Even Ice
was even Ice literally was like, "Yeah, that's true." Ice has
literally said everything that I've said is true. It's just ridiculous.
Maddie is gorgeous, though. And you know what? She's also very
sweet. You know who else? My husband has tried to sleep with
Maddie. A very beautiful girl that has been nothing but nice
to me and I'm nothing but nice to her and she didn't fall for
it and she didn't make it easy. So, shout out. There's not If
you see a woman online, there is no there is there is a 0% chance
that Tim has not messaged her. 0% chance. That's just the trick
of the trade. I just have to be it's just what it's just what
it is. It's just what it is. Who is Maddie in the streamer world?
I don't know. Who? Nobody that I know. Nobody that I know. I'm
sure that Maddie has selfrespect because she didn't sleep with
my husband. So, that at less for something. That counts for something.
And not for his lack of trying. Goonar is who base ghost wishes
he was. Yeah. Tim has never messaged me and my grim messaged
my grandma yet. What a jerk. I bet he has messaged Nacho Mama.
Go through what Kimmy said. I don't have the screenshots. Does
someone want to send me the screenshots? If someone wants to
send me the screenshots of what she said about me or about whatever,
I'll post it. I'll go over it, but I don't have them on me here.
This is my invite people. I'm copying my Discord. I'm putting
it in chat so that if you guys want to send me screenshots, you
can post them. Ice head with Goonar. Who cares? Goar's a Gunnar's
a Did Kimmy really Burger Planet? I don't know. I don't know.
Did he call her pretty? Did he call her pretty? and buy her a
snack. Okay, I'm I posted my Discord. I posted my Discord. If
you guys want to join, get in there and give me some stuff to
go over cuz I I'm not in her Discord and I don't have screenshots.
She doesn't start [__] She ends it. Yeah, I knew
that they Did you just do your nails? No, it's been weeks. I
knew that him and Kimmy had for three years. For 3 years. I knew
the second he did it because he threw it in my face. You should
be here. You should be here. Fine. I'm going to lash out. Fine.
I'm going to Kimmy. Okay. I have a boyfriend. Okay. Hope you
and your man had a great time. Anyway, we did. We actually I
feel so connected with him after that. You sent a clip. What
is this? I'm scared to click it. It's going to be like gay. I'm
so scared that you guys are going to make me pull up like
not going to show it on screen. God, I'm thinking about how nice
I was to I baked cute so many cookies. It's okay. She lived with
Kimmy though. She has to take her side. But still, it's like
it's so weird that she's doing what she's doing to Tim. Especially
because she knows that Kimmy's a psycho. I don't know why she's
acting like Kimmy wouldn't be a psycho to me. Of course Kimmy
was a psycho to me. Of course she was. So I guess she's just
upset that I went harder on Kimmy because I could. Because I'm
capable of destruction.
But like, okay, then you should tell her not to [__]
with me. I don't. If you're really her friend, you should tell
her not to [__] with me. >> Last I knew they
weren't together. >> Gets cheated on. This shows like the
level of >> Yeah, I think they're not together anymore.
dude gets cheated on by his girlfriend and then tries to get
my girlfriend to cheat on me.
Like I don't know if he's trying to pretend it has something
to do with content because obviously it doesn't. His event ends,
he's not going to be doing anything. He's like, "Hey, want are
do you want to come to America?" Like what the [__]
And he puts it on disappearing messages. I mean, I kind of said
it like already, but I mean that's really up, man. And it it
kind of shows like why Kimmy might have felt so uncomfortable
during the Japan stream if he was kind of you know in a way being
very towards Nana during >> I would not I do not want Kimmy's
life at all. Ice Poseidon has cheated on her and messaged most
of her friends. Like I she is in a constant state of war and
insecurity and I think that he genuinely deserves to be cheated
on. If she did cheat on him, he deserved it is what I'm saying.
Like I I don't think I think she's genuinely a victim of abuse
in their relationship. And I think Ice Besidon is a scumbag.
That doesn't take away that Kimmy's a psycho and has been super
weird to me. But if we're choosing sides on like who's worse
in the relationship, it is absolutely Ice Boseidon. And Kimmy
does deserve better. And I'm sure Kimmy would be less insecure
towards me and herself and feel better if she was in a happier
relationship, which is something that I sent her. I said that
you deserve a quiet and enduring love. And then she was like,
"And don't talk about me and Paul because he could say something
cuz he has nothing to lose." I was like, "Okay, bitch." Like,
"Okay, me and M are good and we're friends. Any of that drama
is in the past and we laugh about it now." Oh my god. We literally
laugh about how I tried to ruin her life for just getting messaged
from Paul. Like we we literally laugh about how I tried to blackball
her for from everything. Okay, girl. If you're laughing about
that, she if Maddiey's laughing about that, it's like with she's
like he he he and because she's a very sweet girl, but you are
not laughing about that. The only reason why you are close to
her is 100% so you know if he tries to message her is the only
reason you're friends with her. I'll keep holding back. I'll
continue laying low and it's just insane and sad. Keep holding
What are you holding back, [__] There's nothing like
you are not holding back. There's nothing for you to say. I'm
keeping I'm keeping it until it's either 100% over or until Paul
says I can. I would I can't wait. Kimmy, I if and you're watching
this. I know that you are because Tim has told me that you watch
every single girl streams and comb through streams to know if
someone's talking about you because you're obsessed with yourself.
I know you're going to see this. I hope you step to me. I hope
that I show you that only the people who feel bad for you will
pull back their punch. If you step to me, I will literally destroy
you. It is who I am by nature. If you try to, especially with
the way that you were trying to ego me, you don't get to do that.
Nobody talks to me that way. Sorry. So, if you were smart, you
wouldn't. But I look forward to the future if you do. You're
>> okay. You're going to get base ghost >> I mean,
>> okay, dude. No one's going to believe that [__]
>> And I have actual >> photoshops are obvious. >> Yeah,
but I have real. Does this not come off as someone like a dad
who's talking to his seven-year-old daughter? Is that Let's listen
to this one more >> Okay, you're gonna get base goes to
Photoshop. No one's going to believe that [__] >> And
I have actual >> photoshops are obvious. >> Yeah,
but I have real stuff, too. >> Like what? >> I'm
not going to tell you. >> They're just having this conversation
over dinner. Why are you guys together? Why are you guys together?
So random. Like why are you having a calm dinner where you're
talking about how you could destroy each other? What is going
on?
Dude is filming so his girlfriend doesn't blackmail him. Totally
healthy relationship. Hannah just went live. She's going to defend
Kim against you. Okay. Hannah is live. She's planning to diss
you. Okay. I have nothing against Hannah. If she wants to get
her if she wants to go toward if she wants to get her girl, then
she can. I know literally nothing about her. They have to stay
together because they have career-ending blackmail of each other.
Why are you
Why are you together then? Why are you together? Also, she hates
Hannah. That's another thing. That's another thing. Her and Hannah
are on and off relationships, too, because she Kimmy is weird
with her girlfriends.
Kimmy is weird with her girlfriends. Kimmy said something in
her message towards me that uh Lav has no friends. What? I've
had I've had my friends my girlfriends for years. I've never
had a falling out with any of my girlfriends that I have now
ever. And we've known each other since we were like 14, 11. What
are you saying? What? Like actual the craziest projection in
the world. In the world where you're having like the you're having
every other week you're talking to your boyfriend about how much
you hate your friends and they're talking to their boyfriends
about how much they hate you. Why are you This is I don't understand
this. I don't understand why people do this. It's so low vibrational.
It's so low vibrational.
Why didn't you feel bad about hurting Kimmy? Because she's a
Because she's a The only reason I feel any sympathy for Kim is
because she's so alone always. Her brain isn't right. She needs
to get on meds. She needs to get on meds. She needs to be in
a relationship with someone who genuinely loves her and wants
to take care of her is what she needs. And it can't be my man.
Girl, I know you see how he's my handler. There's only room for
one. There's only room for one. Play the video I posted. Okay.
I'm not going to play it, though. I'm just going to listen to
it because I'm scared that you guys are posting. Give me all
of Kimmy's logs. Where's the Where's the long one where we were
fighting where I said where she said that I married him and the
super long one where she brought up Tim's mom. I want to go over
that one. I want to go over that one. Even Ice says he hates
their friends. Also, aren't these people from the Cubot house?
Don't let Malik or Janine, you're so cringe. You hurt my feelings
so much. You don't even care. Oh, dude. She that is one thing
is she was always saying how mean Tim was to her in their messages.
They'd be completely friendly and she'd be like, "You're so mean
to me. You're so mean to me. You need to be nice to me. You're
so mean to me." And he'd just be like, "Dude, it was like constant.
She just needs like she needs constant validation of how pretty
she is, how much like that she's needed or wanted. Like, girl,
make yourself useful.
Make yourself useful. Why are you like why do you need someone
a man to tell you that you're like worthy of existence all the
time? Like get your together. Don't let Malik or Jaw No, Malik,
please tell me. This is This tells me nothing. The screenshot
tells me >> soon. So I'll leave my cable. >> I'll
leave my cable soon. >> Oh,
goon is a coward for not just telling me manto man and lab is
a mentally ill weird ass dog.
You want to talk about mentally ill and you've been with like
a I went to the psych ward last week. Your girlfriend has a [__]
permanent residence, dude. And you're putting her there first
of all. You're putting her there first of all, but you I have
literally I've never talked to someone as emotionally unstable
to the point where like there's no light behind her eyes as Kimmy
and you want to talk to me about mental illness. Okay. Okay,
dude. And what is it? Tim's just going to Hey, dude. I [__]
your girlfriend. Is that okay? I still want to do Hunger Games.
There's no way you're that [__] stupid, dude. There's
no way you're that stupid. I met my wife in the psychord. We've
been together for 15 years. That's beautiful. Who's that man
voice? Is that your dad or that Tim guy? Tim is my daddy. So,
do you know anything about Miss PBJ and Kimmy beefing? No. No.
PBJ, another girl that I am friendly with that Tim has tried
to have a thing with. I'm there's so many women in this space
that I have completely sweet normal relationships with that I've
reached out to that they've been really nice to me and there's
never been an issue. Never been an issue. They didn't hook up
though. I would never I would never lie on on her name like that.
All the girls he hooks up with have nice booties. Are you jealous?
I have a nice butt. It's just small, but I have a nice butt.
He's also a boob guy though. And then it's not all the girls
you know of the girls that he's hooked up with. Let me be so
clear that there are no small number of them. You might think
that you know what they look like. There is not. It's anything.
It's anything and it's everything. He's tasted the colors of
the rainbow. L's are very nice. Thank you. Are they fat? My
I don't know. Didn't he bang Murk off the perk? No, but not for
lack of trying. What does it What does it mean when Murk When
Murk off the perk has more respect for herself than you do? Not
even Merk would have with Tim. Not even Mk. What is his body
count? Can you hint at it just for fun? No. Nick Wickley is watching.
Hi, Nick Wickley. I was the person who asked about uh the only
fans advice in your um your chat yesterday or the other day.
Yes, she would. No, I wouldn't. I don't even want to know. I
don't even think that you know what your body count is. And I
don't even care. Ew. You're gross and dirty and used up. Merk
was too busy with Darius. Yeah, they smaller but cute. In what
world are my small? Were you saying the same thing? Ow. Oh my
god. My leg is completely asleep. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my
god. Oh my god.
bra is cheating. Yeah. Well, every girl wears a push-up bra on
here. So you look small because your head is overwhelmingly hooch.
Well, you're average at best. Yeah, that's what people say about
me. Goyam,
why are you so jealous of goons and hookups? Holy [__]
Holy [__] I'm not. So, who's Kimmy again? I don't
know. I don't think anyone knows. She's very elusive and mysterious.
Can we get a Troy Gavony breakdown of the Lavon ice drum? Yeah,
they cute. Too big. Ain't that nice? Yeah, I'm only 5'2. 51.
I'm only 51 and a half, too. Will you recap the stream? I was
outside mowing. Yeah, small TL TLDDR. Kimmy has been trying to
posture herself above me with Tim in a very desperate and insecure
display for months and months and months which is why I did not
care about not months and months and months since dream hack
since finding out that me and Tim were in a serious relationship
and it's why I did not care if she was used as collateral towards
Ice. Two birds one stone didn't care. Baso said Kimmy wins and
you lost and she owns you. Well, I'm glad that Tim I'm glad that
Kimmy at least has a place to live right now. Base Ghost, you
are very charitable. Did you meet Luddy briefly?
Basic ghost called you a stupid in ISIS Discord. Isn't Bhos like
54? Do you like Alexis? I've never met Alexis. What did I miss?
We're on a 30 second slow mode. Yeah, CX Chatter's joint. But
I um I think uh the drama is um pretty much done now. We're going
to continue to live our life. I Tim is going to do a a recap
of the scavenger hunt. Basically, is it Kimmy senton? He's going
pretty hard on you in Discord. I'm sure he is. He's a Discord
mod. What else the What else is he going to do? I thought she
was living at Zena's house with Shuy. Oh, no. It's really over.
It's really over for Paul now. Drama's mostly over. I wanted
to give my own account up without Tim to He's going to give his
own account. He's going to go over the scavenger hunt and then
the drama on his own probably. And that'll probably be the last
time. If Kimmy and Paul do get back together, I think it's a
bad idea for Kimmy mostly. I I don't know why you would try to
be with someone who wasted a decade of your life. Not even sure
if he wanted to be with you. I would assure you, I would I would
tell you to have respect for yourself. You're a beautiful girl
and you could do a lot better and you could be with someone who
is not mean to you and who understands you and have a have a
nice, sweet, and enduring love. And uh if I had to give advice
to Paul, I would say if your values are money and status, you
are going to attract women with those same values. And um I hope
that you learn something. Um you're just jealous because she's
going to be rich probably. You just started a war to get more
views and subs. I wasn't even streaming. So are you worried about
running into them at future events or no? No. No. If I did run
into them, what is going to happen? Is Ice going to fight Tim?
Kimmy keeps posturing herself above you. Can you give actual
examples? I can't give actual examples without incriminating
other people uh with screenshots or what they've told me about
what she said. But Kimmy did us the absolute pleasure of doing
it in the message that she sent the other day when she tried
to bring up how Tim's mom asked where she was at her wedding.
Like she's she's trying to place herself in the narrative of
of my wedding with Tim. Why are you doing that? What? She did
not even know that you were dating or they weren't even dating.
She didn't even know that you guys were those are tiny kazar
milkers. And I think that she I think she let the mask slip for
a little there cuz like why why would you publicly that optically
and maybe she's just too stupid but optically that doesn't look
good when you're trying to get back with your boyfriend uh that
you're like trying why are you trying to posture yourself in
Tim's life? Why are you trying to show that you're important
to Tim while you have a boyfriend? And it's stuff like that.
It's like little stuff like that where it's like weird as what
she's been doing to me for months which is weird. See, you finally
answered my question. I follow. Good. Thank you. I wish I was
invited to the wedding. Free food and booze. We would have left
Kimmy to be at the wedding. There is no reason why she couldn't
be at the wedding. Literally, she could have been. There was
That's We invited people and they didn't come and we just forgot
about her literally. But there's literally no reason she couldn't
have come. Burger hit it before Gunnar. I have no idea who Burger
even is. Who else has Kim manipulated and blacklisted besides
Maddie? Well, she tried to do it with Tim or she tried to do
it with Malik who Ice Boseidon also messaged. And she's tried
to do it with other people who I don't want to incriminate. Who
I don't want to incriminate because they're scared. I'm not scared,
but I'm not going to put my friends in line of fire. Seeing Ice
show up after the event, smiling around the contestant shows
he was right. He has something to be proud of in his life and
the community created. Meanwhile, the three of you are slinging
mud with this BS. Listen, I didn't want to kill Ice Poseidon.
I think I did exactly what I was set out to do, which is that
I humbled him a little bit. He realized that you could have all
the money in the world and it would not make up for what you
lack. I still think that there's hope for him. I still think
that there's hope for him. I think that him laughing today after
the his stupid scuffed ass event showed that he can build something.
He's not useless. And I I honestly I hope that he moves on from
his relationship that he's clearly not happy in. And I hope that
he finds happiness. Like I hope that he changes his life. Why
do you think you have the right to teach him this lesson? I mean,
I'm not teaching it to him. I was involved in it just because
I could. I think literally just because I could. No one is perfect.
Yeah. I don't think anyone has to be perfect. In a way, that's
you posturing yourself above him. I think in some ways I I am
above him. Maybe not money and status, but I I think that it's
always a good lesson to He kept, you know, making jokes that
me and Tim were like uh poor and stuff. And um I don't give a
f I could live I loved him so much. I could live in on a mattressless
floor with him. I could I don't want to I don't want to. I didn't
want to start the relationship that way. I wanted to see some
initiative which he gave me. He changed his whole life for me.
He went back to his hometown, started working for the family
business, gave me a house. Like, he's given me my whole life.
He's he's provided me for me in a way that is that is he really
he quested for me and he proved himself to me and we have a beautiful
relationship, but even if he lost everything right now, if he
was in a horrible accident and I had to take care of us forever
or I had to take care of him forever, I would without a second
thought. And I think that's what makes you rich. Not to get like,
you know, gay, but I do think that that just that is the only
thing that matters. I've never felt so connected to anyone in
my life. There was someone posted, "They are absolutely perfect
for each other." And I don't mean that as a compliment. And I
think that's funny, but I also for better, for worse, richer,
for poor, sickness, and in health. I would I will love him until
the day I die with all of my heart and my body. Do you think
part of the reason Ice likes Kimmy is cuz he knows he can treat
her badly and she won't leave? A more intellectual, independent
woman would not tolerate abuse? I think that's part of the reason
why Tim wanted to have sex with her, too. I think that
you girls like Kimmy are a sponge with no self-respect,
no boundaries. They will not speak up for themselves. They will
not, if you are giving them all the validation that they want,
they will stay with you. If you call them pretty, if you show
that you desire them, you can treat them however the [__]
you want. And it's easy. Men like easy. Yeah, I think that he
does probably like that. But I think that the other hand is that
he hates her. I think that he resents her. I think that he hates
how stupid she is and that she can't go toe-to-toe with him.
I think that he wants someone who's more capable and useful and
would be a good mother for his children and who would take care
of the house without him having to take care of her. I think
he probably hates having to be like her dad, having to make her
make it so that he's she's not trying to kill herself all the
time. I think both things are true. So 10 years. Yeah. 10 years.
You know, if you want to marry someone, 10 years, you know. Hannah's
talking about Kim. You're talking about Kim. Kim is loving this.
She loves attention. She can have it. Ice argues with her without
for hours a week. Yeah. I don't know why you would want to do
that in your life. You said Kimmy is known to be blacklist other
women, but now she's sounding like a victim today. Uh I think
Kimmy is not I thought maybe she was manipulative, but over the
last 24 hours I realized that she's just out of control. I don't
think that she's manipulative. I think she's she's acting on
primal instinct to avoid abandonment and insecurity
and to make herself feel significant. So, I don't even think
that she does it on purpose. I I I don't think she's calculated.
I think she's out of control. Doesn't she have BPD? I don't know
her diagnosis makes sense. I'm changing my slow mode. Kimmy's
lies don't even make sense when like the fact that your roommates
are all on different pages. The fact that Jordan deathly ill
is like in comments saying Tim kept uh she kept rejecting Tim
and then and then it is and then Kimmy's like yeah like it's
everyone everyone has a different narrative. You want to stream?
>> wait. Let's form a clip. >> Okay. So, I'm going
to be upset over what do you want me to be angry about? >> Not
enough. >> What have you done that off? >> I haven't
done the laundry. >> You haven't done the laundry? Okay.
All right. You going to do the laundry? >> No. Not going
to do the [__] laundry.
>> Yeah. You stupid little little skank only fan.
>> You're not going to do the [__] >> You're
stealing my jokes. You're stealing my jokes. >> You're
not going to do the laundry cuz you're busy being an only fan
skank all day. Is that what you're doing?
>> I'm sorry. >> You naughty little [__]
>> I'm sorry. >> You naughty little >> I'm
sorry. >> How dare you? >> I'm sorry. How dare you
not have my >> My shorts are short. >> I know. >> You
got legs like mine, though. >> Why do my lighting looks
so much different than yours? >> Yeah, cuz you actually
have legs. >> Well, no, but I I guess your camera's just
better. My camera sucks. >> Hi, puppies. Hi, puppies.
>> Chat, do you have questions for Tim before he starts
chat? Any any questions? Fire away, guys. Let's make some noise.
>> Threat with Don. Why would she do that if they weren't
serious? Kimmy was threatens whoever will [__] listen
to her. This is a healthy relationship. This is how it should
be.
>> Does Did Kimmy have a serious relationship with ice
besides his chat? Why does your husband wear Daisy Dukes? >> Hey,
leave that fret alone. >> Why do you wear Daisy Dukes?
>> Run. Run, Bruna.
>> Oh, why did you think Jack Cameron felt >> Uh,
well, the first time we had I was really excited and I thought,
"Oh, she's a total of like a bunch of tattoos. I didn't realize
you were like a delicate little flower with some graffiti written
all over you." So, my read was like, >> I wanted it fast
and dirty." >> Yeah. I thought, >> even though I
made you wait a year and a >> Yeah. I thought that I was
just going to be like putting on a I wanted it to look like a
crime the first time we did it cuz I thought you were into that
cuz you had black short hair and you looked like you smoked cigarettes
and all that stuff. So, sorry. Context clues threw me >> I
forgot to take off my foot message. Now, there are going to be
clips of me talking about this and it's going to be
>> Where's your foot message? >> Five subs. Feet
for 5 minutes. It's so over. We don't have to pay rent. >> It's
over. >> Like we we have no bills. >> She looks like
your daughter because you're so big and
>> You do actually look You want to >> do you have
a good day? >> Can you just make make my waist look Show
them how tiny my little waist is with your big hands. Okay, but
you're you're cover just outstretch >> Oh, this? >> Yeah.
Cute. Okay, stop touching me. Okay, guys, get out. >> Come
on, baby. I'm going to be late to my stream. >> Let me
say goodbye. Look what time it >> Let me say goodbye without
you. >> We do everything together. >> No, we don't.
>> I was going to let you feature on my live stream. >> Oh,
were you?
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Longest intro ever. Yeah. Tim ignored
all my questions. Peter Griffin, what are your questions? What
are your questions? One last chance. Tell him to paint his toys.
He has been. >> This is the >> Okay, that's it. No
more questions. That's it. He asked about Mr. Girl. What about
Mr. Girl? I'm starting a podcast with Mr. Girl. We're back, baby.
We've never been more back. Okay, can I leave now? After this,
I'm gonna leave up this bod and I'm I'm never going to talk about
this again. Unless there are like new stuff, I'm just like never
going to talk about it again. It's sort of And I don't even know
why Ice cares that much that Kimmy adds to someone else. Who
gives a And I don't know why Kimmy keeps trying to insert herself
in me and Tim's relationship. Be happy. Be happy with your own
life. You're hopefully about to get married if you do. Be happy.
Do your thing. Tim and I will be on camera for money because
I support both of us with my only fans. So yeah, love you guys
and I will see you
never I'll see you tomorrow. I'll try to stream every day this
week probably, but playing Marvel Rivals. Goodbye.